a new cbs news poll out finds out today
rather finds that the country is split
on impeaching the president for a second
time
just 55 percent of americans are in
favor of it
democratic senator chris murphy of
connecticut joins us now
senator good morning to you this thing
seems to be a sure-fire bet
in the house which means what happens in
the senate will determine whether
there's actual removal for the president
or
other repercussions the tantalizing
question this morning
is where is mitch mcconnell what are you
hearing is he
support the house effort alone or is he
actually a yes on impeachment himself in
the senate
well i don't know how mitch mcconnell is
going to vote
ultimately but what i do know is that it
is unclear whether we can actually have
a peaceful transition
of power while donald trump is in office
he has done
nothing substantive to try to tamp down
those individuals who look like they're
coming back to washington to try to
finish what they started
last wednesday uh and he has um
i think demonstrated absolutely no
remorse for the incitement he engaged in
there's reporting now that
he had a chance to send a clear message
early on in the assault on the capitol
that his supporters should stand
down and he would not do that i don't
know what's impeachable conduct if this
isn't and
uh all i care about right now is making
sure that we have a peaceful transition
of power that joe biden has sworn in
uh and right now it is unlikely that
that can happen so long as donald trump
is in office i think there'll be
substantial republican votes for
impeachment today and if that's the case
then there might be substantial
votes to convict in the senate what does
it mean for
joe biden's agenda at this moment where
we're facing a twin economic and health
crisis also
his appointments they need confirmation
as well are you concerned they could be
held up
well you know already we're going to
have a gap with respect to
leadership at the department of defense
and department of state normally
you would be having hearings right now
on the secretary of state the secretary
of defense and mitch mcconnell has
chosen
not to do that i mean listen we are
blessed to have an incoming president
who ran on a platform of reconciliation
of bringing people together
joe biden is uniquely made for this
moment
yes he's going to have to act quickly to
get the vaccination
campaign back on track to restart our
economy but he is also
someone who has done a really good job
over his career in bringing people
together of different ideologies and
different beliefs and
boy we're going to need that now more
than ever currently i'm aware of
no republican senators who have said
publicly that they are
yes on impeachment and those who have
come out have said they're against it
because of
unity now on the one hand that is a
convenient way of not talking about
donald trump anymore
on the other hand we're talking about a
very high alert on the capital
unity is definitely an issue do they
have a point
well what i know is that countries that
have experienced insurrections
like the one that we went through last
week those that skipped the
accountability phase those that just
excused
engaged in that violent act those are
the countries that don't recover
those are the countries that have a
continued insurrection mounted against
their country and so we need to hold
those that were responsible accountable
and those were
the individuals who stormed the building
but it is also president trump and his
enablers
in congress so we don't send a message
to everyone that engaged in
this act of that they are going to be
held accountable for it
let's see what happens in the house
today i think there is a a potential
that there will be substantial
republican support
for impeachment especially if in the
next couple days the president continues
to say things like you did yesterday
that are just providing more fuel to
those that are planning
to come back and try to interrupt the
inauguration so let's talk about that
fuel let's talk about security
our david martin just heard from a
defense official who says the threat
level at the capitol is quote
very high adding higher than has been
reported
in the press and just yesterday you were
told among other things
that a bulletproof vest would be a
reimbursable expense
for senators do you feel safe on capitol
hill
i do feel safe on capitol hill i plan to
be at the inauguration i think it's
incredibly
important that we show to the country
and to the world that we can
uh transfer power peacefully in this
country and we're going to do that
anybody who is intent on trying to
interrupt that process
on wednesday on the 20th is going to be
stopped and they are going to be sent to
jail for a very
very long time yes the threat level is
high we received a
briefing yesterday but security at the
capitol will be
at an unprecedented level and there is
no way
that the folks who got to the capitol on
wednesday of last week will be able to
get anywhere
near the inauguration this time around
they will be stopped if they show up i
hope they don't
senator we've got to go but i want to
clarify one point are you aware of
any republican senators who are
currently right now privately yes
on impeachment
i i am not aware of any senators right
now
who are yes i know many of them are very
open to voting to convict the president
i think they're waiting to see
uh what the articles are and what the
vote is today in the house of
representatives
all right senator chris murphy thank you
very much